our next guest is an emmy and peabody
drop the mic winning
uh author and host not to mention the
mastermind behind the ever popular and
ever memed a real housewives franchise
he is sprinkling even more joy into our
daily lives with his new book glitter
every day
365 quotes from women i love what a
curation oh we all need this book so
badly please give a warm welcome to
andy i have to say this set is even more
breathtaking in person really this is
incredible oh my god i love your watch
by the way oh thank you is that a man's
watch um i and maybe yeah i love a lady
in a man's watch i love a lady in men's
cologne too oh really yeah
i love it i love it i love it you know
what else i love andy your book thank
you i love it so much
it's very you okay i went through
my spoiler alert i went through the
whole year
um but i was very excited because my
birthday is charo
oh my god that's great it's a little
piece of glitter every day it's a
glitter a day and what does charo say on
your birthday i married a guy that is
good looking but i'm married because he
also have a lot of money
um this is everybody you need this this
is fantastic it's like a advent calendar
of positivity yeah humor
wisdom
this is how we all have to start our day
andy thank you drew this is going to be
huge thank you really
you know
women have been inspiring me from my mom
to all the mentors i've had in my career
to divas that i grew up loving from
diana ross to madonna and beyond to all
the housewives and so i thought why
don't i put all the wisdom that i've
gotten from them in one book and there
it is it's so smart and it's beauty week
here and we actually had a news story um
yesterday about your dear friend sarah
jessica parker
bow down
bow down bow down
and i am loving her tone
right now in this vogue article
taking everybody to task a little bit on
the hypocrisy
of women being taken down about their
age and how that doesn't happen to men
yep i yeah we were at we were at lunch
yeah and there was a paparazzi and she's
sitting next to me
white hair silver all the articles were
uh sarah jessica parker's girl you know
she's going gray
and she looks old and it was insanity
and here she is sitting next to me
who's gray and people just missed the
mark totally it was so misogynistic
and she was so right uh and i think that
this new um sex and the city iteration
and just like that is going to be quite
revolutionary because from what i
understand it's going to show the women
you know living vibrantly in their 50s
and you know at this stage in their
lives and she's not going to be running
around in a tutu
and high heels and they're they're going
to be living in their 50s as beautiful
women and i i think it's going to be a
wonderful message
i grew up in an industry that was so
about looks if i had heard one
person
talk about how after 30 it's over i just
was like this is so
toxic and women who are like i'm afraid
to get old i gotta keep it tight and get
on that treadmill every day and eat a
crumb i was like you're miserable
this is such
i hate it
i'm not gonna live my life according to
these screwed up values
let her eat lunch
women go pray go call your mother
i am just joking
let them eat lunch letter eat lunch and
anyone who touches sjp meet me in a dark
alley at 8 p.m tonight i'm gonna take
you down i'll be there too thank you
i'll be there too thank you
[Music]